Trascrizione: Fatbardha Hoxha
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Eccoci.
Bug.
Ho passato i primi dieci anni
della mia vita professionale
a cercare bug.
Che cosa sono i bug?
In informatica sono
le vulnerabilità dei sistemi,
gli errori nella programmazione,
quelle cose che gli hacker usano
per fare in modo che il sistema
si comporti in maniera diversa
da quello che è stato programmato
per fare.
Ho passato i successivi
10 anni della mia vita
a cercare i bug negli esseri umani.
Perché anche gli esseri umani
hanno dei bug,
si chiamano normalmente
cognitive biases.
Sono degli errori in come pensiamo,
degli errori che
possono essere sfruttati
nello stesso modo in cui si usano
i bug dell'informatica,
per convincerci di qualcosa.
Lo faccio da mattina a sera,
tutti i giorni,
occupandomi di
reputazione,
che cos'è la reputazione?
La reputazione è
una condivisa o comune percezione
data dai discorsi che vengono fatti,
su di un brand,
una persona o un prodotto,
dalla totalità dei soggetti
che ne parlano.
Non è realtà.
Non prendiamo una decisione
basata su cosa è vero
e che cosa è falso.
Prendiamo delle decisioni
sulla base di quello che gli altri dicono,
rispetto a un qualche cosa.
Non importa che sia vero o sbagliato,
non importa che sia culo o non culo,
importa cosa ne dicono gli altri.
Sempre e comunque.
E finché lo si fa su di una persona
o su di un brand,
ci possiamo anche stare,
quando questa cosa si fa
per influenzare in generale
l'opinione pubblica
il concetto di reputazione cambia nome
e si trasforma in propaganda.
La propaganda non è una scienza nuova.
Anzi forse il più grande esperto
lo trovate dietro di me, in quella slide,
lui si chiama Joseph Goebbels,
il ministro della propaganda
del Terzo Reich.
Teorizzò una serie di punti
che sono ancora oggi
alla base di tutta la propaganda
che voi avete visto
in tutte le guerre e tutti i conflitti
successivi al Terzo Reich.
Era difficile fare propaganda però,
serviva una presenza sul territorio,
servivano ingenti capacità economiche
per corrompere, spesso,
i giornali e i giornalisti,
serviva attaccare i volantini,
serviva a convincere le persone,
serviva un dispendio enorme
logistico, strutturale ed economico,
ma nel frattempo il mondo cambia
e la propaganda diventa digitale.
E con la propaganda che diventa digitale,
il gioco cambia.
Che cosa è successo nel frattempo?
Beh, da più di un anno a questa parte
faccio un video ogni giorno
dove inizio sempre con la stessa frase,
e la frase è:
"Ciao, Internet!"
Sembra una frase esclusiva,
sembra quasi che io mi rivolga
a una piccola quantità di persone,
solo quelle sull'Internet.
Niente di più falso.
Non esiste oggi come oggi una definizione
più inclusiva che dire "Ciao Internet"
perché sei italiani su dieci
si informano e si formano delle opinioni
cercando in internet.
Ci sono gli altri, già
però buona parte di questi altri
parlano con persone
che si sono informate su internet,
e quindi sono influenzati dall'internet
anche se in realtà
non hanno navigato su internet.
Il rimanente?
Beh il rimanente forma ancora un'opinione,
suppostamente informata,
andando a cercarla sui giornali.
Giornali che si approvvigionano
informazioni proprio sull'internet.
E sull'internet,
sull'internet cosa succede?
Beh, sull'internet a questo punto
la propaganda cambia.
Se prima avevo bisogno di
enormi risorse strategiche,
di enormi strategie informazioni,
di enormi e ingenti capitali,
adesso mi basta una poltrona
dall'altra parte del mondo,
una serie di poltrone in cui aggiungere
una serie di persone,
Una serie di persone che nell'ultimo caso,
che forse avete sentito,
vengono chiamate 'Web Brigades':
brigate del web.
Durante le ultime elezioni statunitensi
un corpo di persone,
vicine al Cremlino,
'Internet Research Agency'
ha creato 80 mila contenuti,
prevalentemente informazioni false,
schierate, polarizzate.
80 mila conversazioni tra
il 2015 e il 2017 che,
tramite pubblicità,
non tramite cose
particolarmente complesse,
tramite normale pubblicità,
sono state mostrate a
29 milioni di persone,
le quali hanno interagito,
hanno fatto like, le hanno condivise,
hanno commentato,
in questo modo portando
la visibilità di questi contenuti,
su 126 milioni di persone.
126 milioni di persone influenzate
da poche persone,
in un divano
o in un grande ufficio,
dall'altra parte del mondo.
Con tecnologie enormi?
No, in realtà le tecnologie sono quelle
che abbiamo imparato a conoscere.
La campagna di Trump,
si è principalmente strutturata
con pubblicità mirata.
Mirata a chi?
Persone che finivano
all'interno di dei gruppi,
persone polarizzate.
Tanto importante tanto incredibile
è stato l'effetto,
che lo stesso Facebook
ha dovuto modificare
le sue condizioni di trasparenza.
Creando meccanismi,
che dall'inizio del prossimo anno,
vi faranno vedere
quella pubblicità che state vedendo,
da chi è stata pagata,
quali altre pubblicità
vi sta facendo vedere
e perché voi siete stati scelti.
Ma se pensate che
ci stiamo limitando a Facebook,
sbagliate, sbagliate di grosso.
Sono tutte le piattaforme,
nello stesso modo colpite,
dalla propaganda digitale.
Una grande macchinazione quindi
dei social network, in giro per il mondo?
No.
Un piccolo effetto collaterale
della pubblicità.
Già, perché in un mondo
pieno di contenuti,
pieno di contenuti che,
tanti inserzionisti
pubblicitari vogliono farvi vedere,
la battaglia non è più nel mostrarvi,
la battaglia è prendere
la vostra attenzione.
E per prendere la vostra attenzione
la pubblicità deve essere fatta per voi,
deve essere personalizzata.
La personalizzazione è fondamentale,
perché a questo punto
mi fanno già vedere quella pubblicità
che so che mi piacerà.
I contenuti dei miei amici
che so che mi piaceranno,
quella particolare cosa
che so che ho già comprato.
Personalizzato
e con quei contenuti io farò che cosa?
Interagirò e questo è il sistema
di revenue dei grandi media.
In questo momento
i social network guadagnano,
non quando vi fanno vedere pubblicità,
ma quando voi interagite.
E quindi, fanno in modo
di proporvi quei contenuti
che sanno già che saranno la base
della vostra interazione.
E su questa interazione
voi avrete dei feedback,
avrete qualcuno che vi fa like.
In questo modo aumentando
e secernendo un ormone
un ormone, dopamina,
della felicità
e mano a mano sarete felici
e continuerete a fare tutto questo.
Niente grandi complotti quindi,
nessuna cospirazione in realtà,
semplicemente,
personalizzazione.
Vogliamo tutti essere
dei piccoli fiocchi di neve,
tutti diversi tra di noi.
Le cose che ci vengono presentati
sono quelle che già ci piacciono.
I contenuti che ci vengono presentati
sono quelli che il sistema sa
che ci piacciono già.
Eh ma in tutto questo c'è un
piccolo effetto collaterale,
si chiama
'Filter Bubble',
la bolla dei contenuti,
la Filter Bubble che è quella cosa
che ci divide,
uno dall'altro.
Due bolle,
tu ed io.
Dove io vivo all'interno,
non della realtà,
ma di una piccola bolla
in cui i contenuti
sono già quelli che mi piacciono,
sono già quelli con cui sono d'accordo,
sono già quelli che mi piacciono in più
e con cui interagirò di più.
Ma c'è un problema:
io penso che questi siano
i contenuti della realtà,
quando non c'è niente
di più distante dalla realtà
che non vivere all'interno
di una piccola bolla.
Perché quando arrivo
all'interno della bolla,
Io posso trovare pubblicità e mandarvela
lo so, lo faccio tutti i giorni
da mattina a sera,
per lavoro
e ogni volta che entrata in una bolla
siete influenzabili,
perché io so cosa voi pensate
e posso creare contenuti vicini a voi.
Quindi niente grandi macchinazioni,
niente grandi complotti,
niente rettiliani,
semplicemente tre piccoli passi.
Il primo:
personalizzazione.
I social network personalizzano
i contenuti per guadagnare di più,
non per un grande complotto.
Seconda cosa:
mentre siete personalizzati,
targeting, pubblicità.
Vi posso mandare la pubblicità perfetta.
Vi posso mandare i contenuti perfetti
che io voglio farvi vedere.
E terza cosa:
la perdita di fiducia nella stampa,
perché la stampa,
non è diventata nient'altro
che, anche lei,
schiava della vostra attenzione.
E i titoli urlati,
e le fake news, riproposte
e le finte notizie
e tutta la parte di titoli strillati,
che non hanno spesso
a che fare poi con la realtà,
non fanno niente altro che farvi diffidare
dell'unica barriera che avevamo
contro la polarizzazione,
cioè quella della stampa,
che adesso diventa non più
un vostro alleato nel capire meglio,
ma diventa un alleato della propaganda
nel settorializzarvi.
E una volta che finite in una bolla,
togliervi è praticamente impossibile,
ma anzi partono quelle cose,
i Cognitive Biases.
Tre particolari:
Il primo:
Confirmation Bias.
Siete disposti a credere alle cose
che sono più vicine
a quello già a cui pensate,
se è qualcosa con cui siete familiari,
siete più disposti ad accettarlo,
supinamente,
senza pensarci.
E allora posso creare contenuti simili
a quelli che già voi conoscete,
contro il diverso,
contro quello lontano,
contro i grandi cattivi,
contro la casta,
e indipendentemente dal fatto
che sia vero o no,
voi siete disposti ad accettarlo.
Secondo bias cognitivo:
'bandwagon effect',
effetto carrozzone,
siete disposti a ritenere vere
le cose che, dicono in tanti,
Solo che per dirla in tanti
e farle dire in tanti,
a Goebbels servivano milioni di euro
e volantinaggi ovunque,
qua serve solo per turbare
la vostra piccola bolla,
tanto voi pensate
che quella sia la realtà
e allora li pochi bot,
pochi sistemi automatici,
tanti tweet,
tanti contenuti
e voi prenderete quella decisione,
che io voglio farvi prendere.
E terzo:
'backfire affect',
reagite in maniera violenta
quando qualcuno dice qualcosa
che è molto contro le vostre opinioni
e la bolla di sapone,
che basta un dito per rompere,
diventa una bolla di acciaio,
perché voi non volete uscire dalla bolla.
E sono problemi di tutti gli esseri umani,
non solo vostri,
sono bug negli esseri umani.
E da qui si continua,
perché da qui...
paura.
Perché ci richiudiamo in delle bolle?
Ci mettiamo in delle bolle
perché abbiamo paura di qualcosa.
Che qualcuno ci tolga
le nostre piccole certezze,
che arrivi il diverso,
che qualcuno ci porti via
quel poco che abbiamo.
Ma la paura va bene,
si può discutere,
quando la paura entra in una bolla
diventa dogma.
Perché dalla bolla non mi tolgo più,
perché tutto quello che c'è nella bolla
continuerà a essere per voi vero,
perché voi pensate
che tutti la pensino come voi,
trovate la fede nei numeri
e dove parte il dogma,
a chiunque prova a togliervi dal dogma
parte la violenza.
La violenza contro qualunque idea
al di fuori della vostra,
non importa quale sia
il vostro schieramento.
Perché vi parlo di tutto questo?
Perché siamo in Italia.
E abbiamo tra poco delle elezioni
e abbiamo già visto come sta funzionando
la propaganda in Italia.
Bandwagon effect, ve lo ricordate?
Effetto carrozzone, eccolo,
questo è un esempio di bandwagon effect:
centinaia di finti utenti su Twitter
che vi dicono un'idea
per convincervi di che cosa?
del fatto che tutti la pensano così
e dove quelli non vanno,
basta che qualcuno citi una parola
e parte un altro tipo di bot,
questo si chiama 'Freedom Warrior',
è un bot automatico,
che nell'ultimo referendum
per l'autonomia lombarda
a chiunque lo citava,
raccontava sempre la stessa cosa,
ma sempre convinti che esistesse
una verità storica, assoluta.
E questo non è.
Perché io li chiamo bug?
C'è un motivo per cui li chiamo bug.
Perché in informatica,
per ogni bug,
c'è una cosa che si chiama patch.
Una pezza da mettere,
un sistemare un problema,
un risolvere una vulnerabilità.
E lo si può e lo si deve fare
anche con gli esseri umani,
anche come pensate voi.
Lo si fa in tre passaggi:
il primo, è semplice,
sulla carta: 'pravda'.
Tornare alla verità,
cercare spasmodicamente la verità
al di fuori della vostra bolla,
cercare le fonti delle notizie,
non fidarvi di quello che è
all'interno della vostra bolla.
Solo così riuscirete
a uscire in qualche modo
dal meccanismo
di approvvigionarvi di informazione
È difficile. Vuol dire
mettersi in discussione,
vuol dire cercare attivamente
e non subire passivamente
la propaganda di una verità.
Il secondo passaggio
è andare contro la violenza.
Arrivare e capire
che arriva un punto
in cui la paura diventa dogma
ma quando il dogma diventa violenza
le comunità che lanciano la violenza
devono essere fermate.
Arrivare a capire che dobbiamo
essere parte contro la violenza
e non accettare in nessun modo
la violenza di una opinione,
per evitare di essere influenzati
anche noi.
E la terza in realtà è particolare,
quello che dicono tante persone
che si occupano come me
di sicurezza informatica:
'Paranoia is a virtue':
la paranoia è una virtù.
Siate paranoici,
dubitate di quello che vi accade,
dubitate
sempre e comunque anche
delle fonti che ritenete accreditate,
è faticoso lo capisco,
è difficile lo capisco.
Siamo tutti schiavi della nostra piccola
zona di comfort della nostra comodità,
ma solo così
possiamo pensare di uscire
da quello che è lo story telling politico
che vedrete nei prossimi mesi.
Come chiudere tutto questo?
Beh, con un augurio che faccio sempre
alla fine di ogni mio filmato
che è una frase latina e dice:
'Estote parate':
siate pronti.
Siate pronti a dubitare,
siate pronti a cercare la verità.
Siate pronti a mettere in discussione
le vostre idee,
siate pronti ad agire fermamente
contro la violenza,
siate pronti a sgomitare
all'esterno della vostra bolla,
a sgomitare all'esterno della propaganda,
a rompere la vostra bolla
per sanare quelle che sono
le problematiche dell'essere umano,
i bug degli esseri umani,
perché il vostro compito
è diventare dei nuovi eroi.
E chi sono i nuovi eroi?
Quelli che tentano di migliorarsi,
e in questo modo migliorare
quella cosa di cui facciamo parte tutti,
quella razza umana che deve migliorare,
di volta in volta.
E come sempre,
grazie mille per avermi ascoltato.
'Estote parate'
(Applausi)